this is number 16 in my series of doctor
sailor talkin talks I haven't been doing
these for a while but I'm going to start
up the series again now with a new
smaller chalkboard which means a bigger
challenge because what I try to do in
these videos is give something of a you
know 15 to 20 minute talk on something
that has to fit within the space of the
chalkboard and the frame that I've got
so what I'm talking about today is a
topic that I find very interesting and I
think you might find very useful it's
called the hierarchy of disagreement and
it's a set of ideas that come out of an
essay by this guy Paul Graham who's
originally writing about discussions on
the internet that is having to do not
only with YouTube for example in
comments but boards comment sections on
blogs on all sorts of places anywhere
basically where people can respond to
each other and discuss substantive
issues the problem is much of the time
and many of you know this from looking
at all sorts of comment sections if you
scroll down and past the main story or
you know you look on comments on YouTube
a lot of them end up ignoring the main
issues that their opponents are talking
about when they're engaged in
disagreement and so what Graham wanted
to do is in his essay he wanted to lay
out a hierarchy that is a set of
gradations going all the way from the
lowest to the highest having to do with
the nature of disagreement how effective
it would be what sort of what sort of
consequences would come how useful it
would be in working out your own
thoughts but also in changing other
people's thoughts those sorts of things
and like a lot of people he was bothered
by the fact that much internet discourse
ends up being down here I would say that
that's actually the case not only for
Internet discourse but
much more broadly in any sort of
disagreement that you have whether it's
at the dinner table at Thanksgiving on
the bus with some random stranger if
you're inclined to argue with people in
classes in papers that people write this
this concept of a a set of grades of
disagreement some disagreement being
more on target than others is very
useful and applies I think across the
board that's not to say that I actually
think that this encompasses all modes or
understandings of disagreement I'd say
there's some things that are left out
but I don't want to talk about that in
this video because I want to focus on
what's what's particularly good about
this now there is one other thing to you
notice I'll get this guy black belt
Bayesian put up here as well there is a
seventh level in addition to Paul
Graham's six or actually seven because
he has a zero level seventh level
discussed that's refuting the central
point of an improved argument a lot of
people have written about this this
particular essay by Graham and suggested
where maybe he had a blind spot or was
missing something and they tried to find
some ways to fill it in and perhaps
we'll do another video later on about
the you know other emendations to it but
in any case let's look at what the how
the hierarchy goes what the the
structure what the arrangement is so it
goes from lowest and he's got zero level
which you know means that really
nothing's going on here nothing of any
value all the way up to the the highest
levels where what you're doing is you're
disagreeing with somebody and you're
actually accomplishing something and
you're accomplishing it in an effective
way
so there's name-calling at the first
level ad hominem attacks the second
level responding to tone third level
contradiction fourth level actually
labeled three here you see
counter-argument then refutation
refuting the central point then refuting
the central point in an improved version
of you
argument so there's one thing that's
being assumed here that I do have to
point out at least at the higher levels
the assumption is you're actually on
target in what you're doing with with
your own point of view because because
there's you know no actual questioning
of one's own point of view here but
again that that could be something
talked about in a further video so let's
start at the bottom and work our way up
so name-calling a lot of this goes out
he uses the example asked at which is a
fairly recent term I think only of
Internet Providence and then you know
get made its way into the popular media
but you could think of all sorts of ways
of calling people names it's not
actually refuting anything about a
person's position or argument because
it's not actually engaging it it's
merely yelling at the other person and
doing so instead of you know shouting or
throwing stones it's picking names to
call them and to a certain extent that
blends into an ad hominem attack because
many ad hominem attacks are at best just
mere instances of name-calling if we
want to use the ad hominem very broadly
he is a somewhat more specific
understanding of that in mind but the
basic point is this if you're at the
level of name-calling
you're really not arguing at all all
you're doing is throwing insults back
and forth and you know an argument can
go from these upper levels and
degenerate down to name-calling the more
and more people get frustrated or angry
or lose control of their temper however
you want to put it now ad hominem
attacks why should we treat these as
something distinctly different from
name-calling
well because with ad hominem attacks
attacks against the person so you're
attacking some quality of the person
you're attacking some circumstance of
the person you're looking at the person
is belonging to a certain group or
having a certain point of view by virtue
of their history who they are their
interests their engagements their
alignments
you're just missing the person and their
point of view their argument there their
claims on the basis of who it is that
they are or what qualities they have or
what circumstances they happen to find
themselves in now some of those could in
fact be relevant if you're on the Senate
floor and you're pointing out that your
opponent who is taking a position
contrary to you has taken tons and tons
of money from people who also want him
to take that point of view you could say
well he's actually being self-interest
that he's not actually looking out for
the interest of the people as a whole
that would be an hominem attack with
that that also would be something that
could be relevant whereas if you're just
gonna call him a scumbag that's just
name-calling that's not that's not
relevant the problem is if you want to
be effective in disagreeing with
somebody and you remain at the level of
ad hominem attacks you're not going to
get much done and you set up a bad habit
which is one not only for yourself but
also for other people and that habit is
this instead of looking at what people
are saying and and paying close
attention to that and figuring out
whether it's correct or incorrect valid
invalid you know whether the premises
are good or or whether they need to be
called into question what you're doing
is you're paying attention to the person
and one of the things if you want to be
ineffective if you want to be effective
in critical thinking and argumentation
you do want to pay some attention to the
person but you really want to pay
attention to what's actually being put
on the table what's being said what's up
for contention and and hominem attacks
get away from that that's that's a
problem for the third level to this
responding to tone that's where you're
saying I don't like the way that the the
other person is talking and there could
be a lot of variations on this Graham
doesn't talk that much about that in his
essay but you could think of a lot of
cases where somebody says well you're
angry so I can't talk
if you were discussed these things with
you because obviously you're being
irrational that's going beyond it at
hominem attack and they're just saying
something that could in fact be relevant
tone can sometimes signify whether a
person has actually open to persuasion
or considering another case whether they
consider their opponent to be beneath
them you know whether they're being
contemptuous towards them whether
they're being so towards their audience
or potential audiences or other people
but the trouble again is if you're
paying attention to tone if you're
paying attention to how somebody is
coming across to their word choice to to
you know the context of it you're
playing gotcha games with them in
particular think for example the
slip-ups that people make in
conversation and they say you people and
then somebody says oh you people so you
think we're all the same and they start
getting offended by it that's really
just responding to somebody's tone
that's not actually engaging what it is
that they're saying substantively that's
not actually trying to reach out and
figure out what their point of view is
it's not that effective of a mode of
disagreement it might be effective with
certain audiences because you can get an
immediate reaction or you can you know
get somebody to be ashamed and then try
to make them do what you want but you're
not actually reasoning well in that case
with another person you're not debating
fairly so that's a problem now once we
start getting into these levels what
what do we got going on something a
little bit different we're no longer
paying so much attention to how
something is being said or who is saying
it or just you know throwing stones at
another person now we're actually
engaging in what Aristotle would call
the logical means of persuasion we're
actually looking at what is being said
and we're trying to find some way to
argue against it now one particularly in
effectively
is this this level three here the fourth
of these levels to remember we still
have a zero level which is mere
contradiction stating or restating
position opposed to the opponent and
this can be at the very childish level
of you should know you shouldn't you
should know you shouldn't you are no I'm
not you are no I'm not that's just
contradiction but it can also be done
when your opponent makes an argument and
you say it was just not the case
here's the real case you haven't
actually engaged your opponent you
haven't tackled anything that they've
they've brought out into the the public
forum of discourse into the shared space
of disagreement and dialogue you've just
restated your claim and and there are a
lot of people who do that sort of thing
I remember back in graduate school
having a professor who had sit there and
he would put a put forth a position on a
particular author and then you know
you'd actually engage in this higher
level thing and said well look the text
doesn't actually support that but we
know about the guy he wouldn't have
actually taken that position here is
some other passages where he's thinks
I'm something completely different and
then he would look at you for a minute
and then he would simply restate what
he'd said before with a little bit more
conviction as if now you'd finally get
it sort of like you know we think that
when we're talking to foreigners it's
not just Americans to by the way who do
this that somehow if they're not
understanding us we should talk slower
and shout that's really what
contradiction amounts to it the one good
thing about it is you are at least
engaging in counterclaims to your
opponent rather than just attacking
their person or their tongue
counter-argument now once we start
getting to this level we start getting
the things that are much more
interesting with counter-argument you
are contradicting your opponent you are
saying I think that you're wrong in
saying X that it's actually not X
whatever X happens to be but you're
supplying something else you're
supplying some reasoning or some
evidence at least something that's
supposed to count as evidence maybe your
opponent won't actually concede it maybe
your audience won't concede it but
you're actually offering something
you're saying I think that and you're
also saying here's why that's really
important this is something I stress to
my students all the time it's not enough
to have an opinion when you're doing
academic writing you need to have some
sort of good reason that another person
might be able to accept for advancing
that opinion not necessarily for holding
it but at least for advancing it into
somebody else's space somebody else's
place so there's a problem though you
can do this in such a way that you're
actually engaging tangential points
things that your opponent might actually
concede or be willing to give in on
things that if you attack don't really
undermine the whole structure of their
argument so the higher level would be
refutation you want to be able to say to
your opponent here's where I think that
you've actually got something wrong when
you're criticizing somebody it's you
know you can't just say for example
let's say you're writing an essay about
do you agree with Aristotle's position
on something it's merely an ad hominem
attack to say let's say we take
ourselves position on slavery and then
we talk about Aristotle's moral theory
well Aristotle thought that slavery was
a ok which isn't quite entirely true but
he did say that slavery could be by
nature in some cases and that that's
better for the slave in those cases so
if you just say something like well
Aristotle says slavery is okay so as
moral theories no good therefore I don't
have to study it that's an ad hominem
attack I don't like the way that
Aristotle talks which is actually
the problem with Aristotle more of a
problem is his translators that's
responding to tone no he's just wrong on
this you know everybody's equal that's
just a contradiction counter-argument
you know he's just wrong on that because
you know we've decided that that in
modern times everybody should be equal
okay counter argument now refutation is
where you quote something here's what he
actually says here's why I think it's
it's it's wrong you have to quote your
opponent you have to find some actually
like he calls it a smoking gun you have
to find something that I actually say if
you're attacking your opponent and
you're attributing things to them that
they didn't actually say or you're
misunderstanding what it is that they
say and then you're restating it and
that you know that that Restatement
distorts what they say you're engaging
in what's called a straw man fallacy and
that is not going to be an effective way
of arguing because as soon as somebody
points out well that isn't actually what
he said now your own position starts to
look pretty shaky so refutation you want
to actually be able to point at
something concrete you could paraphrase
but you got to be careful of
paraphrasing you want to find what your
opponent is actually committed to and
then show why it's wrong undermine your
opponent you can do this in such a way
like I said though where it's actually
sort of you know it's chipping away at
the the outside stuff and you're not
getting at the central point that your
opponent is making so there's a higher
level which is actually refuting the
central point of your opponent now in
order to do that what if you have to be
what do you have to be able to do
yourself you have to be able to identify
what the central point is so if you're
muddle-headed about what it is that your
opponent is actually saying and this
could be because they're muddle-headed
themselves or it could be because you
just haven't devoted enough time to
understanding their position then you're
not going to be able to refute the
central point or if you do it'll be just
by accident you have to stumble across
it you want you notice you want to be
able to actually
understand what your opponent is saying
on its own grounds in order to figure
out what the central point is if you are
simply opposed to somebody and you're
looking for gotcha ways to to win them
over or to show that they're a fool or
something like that you're going to be
putting yourself down here at these
levels you're not going to be able to do
this and intelligent people not only are
able to do this they expect that when
other people make a case they're going
to be doing this as well if they're in
disagreement with somebody else
otherwise they're not going to give you
the time of day I you know I look at a
lot of essays online and I actually I'll
admit it I sort of write them off fairly
quickly a third if they're not cogent if
they're not on point if they're not
actually if they're being unfair to
their opponents because I don't know the
time for that sort of BS now black belt
Bayesian he added another level to this
which i think is really good refuting
the central point so how is that
different from this of an improved
argument you take your opponent's
argument and this is what's called the
principle of charity you read them in
such a way so that you know you don't
actually take the opportunities to do
this sort of stuff just engaging like
what I said gotcha moments you treat
your opponent as if they're a rational
person even if you don't think that they
are you say this point of view I think
is really mistaken but how could
somebody actually see it as being
correct without being you know totally
evil corrupt stupid
how could a reasonable person with
common sense well-informed decent you
know human being how could they see
things that way what you're doing then
is you're actually making their argument
stronger now why would you want to make
somebody else's argument stronger if
you're opposed to them well if you think
that you're actually right making their
argument stronger is not actually going
to tell against your argument or your
why not because your argument actually
is stronger so you know if you're up
here and they're down here and you bring
them up to this level not quite where
you are but pretty close you say you
know not only am I going to engage you
here I'm gonna engage you here where you
didn't even go that is an incredibly
effective way of disagreeing with
somebody and with arguing with somebody
if you can do that that is how you win
people over who are opposed to you and
our intelligence and our decent human
beings and have common sense and are
well informed so we've got all these
different levels of disagreement all
these different activities and I would
invite you now you know when you're when
you're thinking about these sorts of
things when you get yourself into the
next argument
ask yourself what level you're actually
working at ask yourself what level the
other person is working at and think
about this where do you want to be on
this being able to do this sort of stuff
or this or even this these are not
things you can just you know snap your
fingers and it's gonna automatically
happen people do this kind of stuff
because they've got bad moral habits and
they've got bad intellectual habits and
habits are hard to break
it takes work it takes exercise that's
why critical thinking and argumentation
is not something that you can just you
know immediately get a textbook and and
start applying you have to work at it
you have to develop these these
intellectual and moral habits in order
to be able to do this sort of stuff the
payoff is if you are able to do this not
only will it make you a better person in
general because you're gonna be less of
a jerk to other people you'll learn more
people will actually pay attention to
you more you'll be much more effective
in whatever it is that you're trying to
do so this has been dr. Sarah Chalke and
talk number 16 I'm going to be
continuing with this series adding more
of these now on the smaller more
challenging chalkboard